unfortunately on Brand's corner has
broken another thing on a trash tea
special I kind of feel like I'm in a
clown car right now this is not going to
be from my dick it's going to be for my
tears I just want to watch anime titties
I don't want to be here
I'm guessing it's quite painful oh
you're approaching I'm going to take
this home
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome to another trash taste special
we're back baby I know it's been a while
and you know what we've been stuck in
the studio during the pandemic so we
thought why not just get out all of the
traveling we've wanted to do in one go
so why not have a bit of a boys trip
across all of Japan and since this trip
was so excruciating long and we filmed a
lot of stuff we obviously can't show you
everything we filmed but for you guys
supporting us over on patreon because
you guys also help us support these
specials then you can get a full
extended version of this special and if
you're interested in that and want to
support the show as well then go to our
patreon patreon.com trash taste links in
the description but enough teasing on
with the special welcome to the start of
the trash taste road trip we are at the
southernmost point of Mainland Japan
SATA misaki ignore the lighthouse back
there but this is our starting point I'm
going to be going all the way to the
northernmost point in Hokkaido nearly 3
000 kilometers about 50 plus I don't
know hours of driving way too long a lot
of driving and hopefully along the way
we'll be finding some fun stuff just
show you guys without further Ado let's
start this guy against you in road trip
across all of Mainland Japan let's go
so beautiful
three thousand kilometers and nine days
to pack in as much of Japan as possible
over that time we will be doing various
activities encountering every climate
from Sun to snow along with a lot of
driving Welcome to the trash taste road
trip
[Music]
well we're about to stop question is
who's driving well me I literally just
got my license two days ago so um I'm
I'm still fresh in uh Japanese driving
laws I get it I get it made the youngest
one do all the work are you going to be
doing any driving this this journey Joe
I'm gonna be in the passenger seat
making sure we don't get lost what the
[ __ ] he gets to sit in the nice comfy
passage you'll see this entire time this
is the only day you get to ride a
shotgun no other time no other day no
other day you don't deserve it shotguns
for winners all right let's go
seat belts on gentlemen I've already got
it on I've already got it on this is a
safe road trip I'm not going to crash
the car I mean yeah
no way has he broken two cars let's go
come true
even though we shared a common goal of
reaching the most northern part of Japan
that didn't mean there wouldn't be some
classic trash taste challenges along the
way we have a couple of like pit stops
of some interesting activities that we
find depending on the challenge there's
a little rewards you get to live the
life of a king or the life of a peasant
maybe I always live the life of a king
we'll see about that bad Beach things so
our first stop is Oita prefecture it's
going to take us about six and a half
hours to get there and uh Oita or rather
bepu is a big city
it's known as a big onset City
stop we'll be going to is hopefully a
nice relaxing Onsen after a six and a
half hour it's kind of where are you
going so Google Maps is conflicting with
the information the the cars at
Aristotle [ __ ] sake agree just blaming
it on the map I am do it's not my fault
we've literally been driving for 11
minutes and we're already lost good
content
[Music]
and there it is
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] tunnel oh my God
what a [ __ ] tunnel one car tunnel how
many times had have you guys had to pee
on a road trip in your lives in a bottle
yeah
I've never done that I did it on my boss
once
you have so many [ __ ] weird pistols
like you're always piss in your parents
room once you piss on a bus in public
apparently I'm not like not in the bus I
mean like in a bottle on a bus I don't
know if that's better though
no so like she had a she had like a
bottle of like peach juice and I was
like down it down and now I need that
bottle thankfully our producers didn't
plan challenges for us on the first day
as we could just relax at our first
destination in Pepper well we have
reached our first destination of the day
my God Conor is already dead I mean I
drove for four hours I'm tired but this
is our first day of driving and uh
pretty pretty good so we're in Oita
Factor right now we're going to stay at
this uh San tsikan right here 111 years
old this real kind apparently are you
the one who booked this one Connor no
what no yes yes I am yes I am yes I am I
was like uh no no I have the booking.com
reservation this is my one it's famous
for its nonsense and I need a bath
because I stink so uh let's go check out
the room though all right all right
let's see our first room for the trip
[Music]
oh this is this is a road trip room this
is the Rio card experience where you
just get a but like your view releases
oh look at that Sakura look at that
Sakura
that's pretty amazing just like took the
room like five levels up basically right
now I'm about to have a high school
romance on this [ __ ] business
[Music]
our relaxation would be short-lived
however as our destination was Fukuoka
where apparently a secret activity was
waiting for us Gamers it is day two of
the trash taste road trip it's 7 30 in
the morning we woke up at 5 30. let's
[ __ ] go we are being fueled purely by
The Cow by the power of the cow hey
you'll get this boy some milk by the
power of caffeine but anyway today uh
we're on our way to Fukuoka which is the
North East prefecture in Kyushu we have
just been told to go to a certain point
we don't know what we're going to be
doing yet apparently some kind of
challenge I don't know if we're gonna be
suffering or having fun I'm pretty
scared honestly gone this is trash taste
we're going to be suffering which one is
it gone was there more doors or Wheels
gone is this an actual question yeah
genuinely what is there more wheels or
dots there's more doors but like your
office like uh chair has like six wheels
I don't know why but whenever con asked
me question now I'm just like is this a
Deez Nuts joke I was like silent because
I'm just like there's no way this can
lead to a Deez Nuts joke of my answer
right that's like Doctor Strange the
meme calculating every possibility it's
like there's no way Connor's trying to
like initiate a genuine conversation I
was thinking we all these nuts in your
mouth door these nuts no that doesn't
work either soon though our destination
came into view all right well we're
three minutes away from wherever the
[ __ ] we're going wherever the producers
have decided it's pretty Barren right
now it's not a whole lot going on I mean
is anything famous in this region that
we could be doing not that I know of
maybe something traditional farming is
it famous for farming a traditional
Japanese experience I'm happy to play
what was it Harvest Moon that's that's
the game I don't want a [ __ ] Farm the
first one to grow carrots wins
apparently it's just around here oh [ __ ]
there's horses at the front what the
[ __ ] are we horse printing are we riding
horses what is this Canadian Camp Horse
Club making
experience we would be doing Yaba Summit
a traditional Japanese sport based
around archery on Horseback this was
something straight out of Princess
Mononoke so those are horses
those are live animals uh that we are
going to be riding as we've just found
out right now really don't want this to
be the thing that I break I don't want
to break a horse I really don't want to
break a wall well the thing is either
you break a horse or you break yourself
just don't break anything today but
either way we need to get changed before
we start and get all the protective gear
on so I guess so let's let's do that
yeah cultural appropriation speed run
I'll be gold I'll be blue all right all
right if Joey still had his long hair
he'd literally just look like a samurai
right now with the bun yeah with the bun
yeah I look like every tourist to Japan
area I feel very Tom Cruise Last Samurai
is kind of vibe right now our first task
would be learning archery which was
tricky enough on Solid Ground so first
and foremost we're gonna get used to
using the actual bow I mean look at this
super traditional ones yeah
I agree if I remember correctly yeah you
put it in between here you wrap your
thumb around it so that it kind of
covers it you've got to use your index
finger and your thumb to kind of grab it
like this and then you twist it a little
pull it back
[ __ ]
okay that was that was awful and I'm
gonna watch Connor alone it's Connor's
getting the full-on tutorial no I don't
want to move yeah
I'm scared
ah so okay okay let me try this
okay what about this I think I got it
how are you guys doing I think I got it
really yeah oh okay
today I will prove the Archer class is
really made up of archers
you should be banned
we're literally just gonna have to do
what we're doing but while we're doing
this yeah that sounds easy that sounds
easy enough like doing it watching
PornHub
shooting a bow while watching porn let's
go let's go let's get out of here let's
get the [ __ ] out of here a good baby oh
good oh
I see a pain in the ass to keep take
care of shoveling the poop all day it's
like following a trash taste episode
shoveling all the [ __ ] takes for two
hours it was time to get on the horse
and it was only then we were informed
that of course we were gonna be
competing for a prize of course we can't
just have fun here on trash taste on a
special we can't have it no it's never
allowed we're here to make winners or
losers apparently the winners get to get
to stay at the Sheraton tonight it's the
only five-star hotel in Hiroshima and
apparently the loser stays in a manga
Cafe I've already done that is it a nice
experience no
it's not you're sleeping on a yoga mat
basically and uh yeah there's going to
be a Target that we have to hit on
horsepower and I guess whoever gets the
least amount of points or least closest
to the Target is the loser let's just
say the manga Cafe I love the fact we
woke up at 5 30 in the goddamn morning
only for me to end up on a yoga mat in
Among Us listen are you admitting defeat
already no I'm obviously staying at the
show I want tonight is a good night's
sleep all right I'm just excited to see
uh Connor lose for once yeah it's about
time I win something I mean I'm half
Japanese so I basically win by default
in this traditional sport so uh yeah
easy diet comes back to bite you easy
diet but I guess for now we'll uh start
riding the horses hey
oh
easy look at them shoes damn dude look
at those Converses Ray J Dude Ray
William Johnson I will call you cafe
damn these are good boys man yeah I know
yeah what a good boy how God feels when
he's telling me he's a pigeon I feel
powerful get off your high horse God you
guys think you're better than me
whenever Connor has an opinion I swear
I'm right POV you're six foot looking
down on Connor how convenient the white
guy goes on the White Horse
we were nervous to start with but
excited to feel the power of shooting
arrows from horseback it's
nerve-wracking I gotta we gotta steer
the horse and shoot the bow it's kind of
weird it's kind of daunting so we're
just practicing to see how what it would
be like
I was trying my best to fire my arrows
but God's horse seemed a bit too Keen to
get friendly with mine Jesus Christ is
right in your ass too I know like he's
like what the [ __ ] he said oh you're
overtaking me what the [ __ ] London
why are they doing this are they kissing
stop kissing why are my butt cheeks gone
get your horse away sniffing the [ __ ]
dude my horse however much like me had
his own pace he was going on you can get
a little bit closer Joey yeah I'm trying
mate Ray J's just hanging out dude
Russia's just chilling man
there we go don't raise it you got it
mate
no no come on you've got me ready
I like to stop man you've got to make it
easier on me
[Music]
Joey's got the easy horse he literally
stops in front of the target yeah he's
giving Joey an advantage what the [ __ ]
it's not my fault he's like bro bro you
got this you got this bro I literally
got the like the stoner of horses
ha ha I missed oh no he missed oh he's
choking he's choking dude
you got a joy
oh he choked he choked chokes I'm the
only one who hasn't missed yet that's
how every every trash day special goes
and then I miss how did Joey Miss with
like the slowest of horses he basically
missed standing still I'm focusing too
hard on like form that I'm not aiming
properly I think that's why I missed
that last one yeah excuses Jake
pressure zero miles an hour
there we go on just choked on one of his
shots I don't know how you did that I
did how did you do that I just looked I
got a misfire classic Gun Man Ray J
really needs some [ __ ] reinforcement
to get going dude I'm kicking the [ __ ]
out of this horse and I feel so bad
don't say that but then practice was
over and it was time to play for real
the two Targets were placed further away
and we'd have three rotations for a
total of six shots whoever gets the most
shots on target wins ready boys all
right good luck good luck Gentlemen
let's go my grip's week arms are sweaty
come on oh my God that's so far
yes
oh that's so far away dude what the [ __ ]
okay got it no one of you please joke
come on Ray J we got this bro we got
this
yes
oh come on Jerry choke this one choke
choke choke my ancestors are looking
watching upon me right now
got it that was so hard to hear this is
nerve-wracking that was close I nearly
missed that I I was before dude I'm
nervous I really want to stay at this
hotel
we're going super hard mode we're going
even Beyond they have no idea that a
five-star hotel is on the line right now
holy [ __ ] miss it
yes yes
oh my [ __ ] god choke Joey please
please I'm begging you the ancestors got
my back
I was the first to miss a shot things
weren't looking good
oh did I go in
oh does that count I did it bounce out
oh of course in true trash tastes
fashion there was a bit of controversy
regarding Connor's points I feel like
Connor's missed the edge he hit the edge
there no no no I definitely got it in I
definitely got it in I definitely went
in I missed the second one I missed both
I feel like Conor missed the second one
as well he definitely knows he missed so
that means in that last one Connor hit
one God hit one I hit zero and we make
it even harder now making it even harder
great this is really hard now my heart
is pounding so much I was in the lead
and ready to grab Victory all I needed
to do was to not choke
[Music]
good luck Jerry
oh did I go in oh did that hit going I
didn't see I honestly didn't see that I
don't think it went in oh no
[Music]
Joey Joey Joey's staying in the manga
yeah
yes I get the nice hotel oh I'm so happy
I'm so happy wait why are there two
winners what the [ __ ] the winner the
winner sorry Ray J we did our best man
who would have thought that the person
who plays the least FPS games would lose
don't play with that your ancestors
where were they your ancestors were your
answers I was German today dude
for the first time in trash taste
history I didn't choke so of course I
took my victory extremely gracefully
well well well choke dog V8 doesn't
strike today that was a first wasn't it
yeah I know no kidding Brad damn that
was really fun thank you very much to
Canadian Club in Fukuoka the staff are
also amazing and really welcoming and
just really a great time overall
honestly that was one of the finest
activities I've done here in Japan
wearing this feels badass you like
channeled your Tom Cruise energy because
you were like Last Samurai in the [ __ ]
I did dude I saw the Gatling gun I
thought I got to get one shot I gotta
kill the guy and also I'm the winner
which is also great did we determine how
many any winners that we're going to be
yeah two well we changed it to one
though yeah we can definitely change it
to one no no no no no what's in the
what's in the rules what's in the rules
well he technically got the most scores
so he has the most scene oh I guess I'll
[ __ ] why would you give it to Connor
either way I'm [ __ ] staying so if
anything I want a robe gone in to be
honest we can read some manga together
get away get away unfortunately it was
decided by Mr humble winner over here
that there would be two losers from The
Challenge staying in a manga hotel at
our next destination Hiroshima it is my
turn in the driver's seat now I'm scared
I will try not to crash the car I've
never driven a vehicle this big before
so this should be an interesting
experience I just want to get to this
hotel in one piece I mean of course it's
the one time I win can't will sabotage
it yeah this should be easy like I I
feel okay I feel anyone who's learned
how to drive in Southeast Asia can like
survive if you can drive in Southeast
Asia you can drive anywhere I might piss
people off but I don't think I'll crash
all right don't never never see you
again I'll break a few laws I'll kill a
few civilians but you know as long as I
don't know we're safe guys that's the
important thing the kids on the side of
the road you know that's their problem
you know they need to look right and
left what did you say again [ __ ] them
kids
finally we had arrived in Hiroshima and
it was time for Connor to enjoy his
prize well we're at the Sheraton Hilton
in Hiroshima boys which should be on our
accommodation our accommodation I can't
wait to stay here tonight I love
five-star hotel so who doesn't I I'm
gonna go in the hotel hope you boys
enjoy your monkey Cafe don't touch me
don't touch me hi guys I'm gonna go die
now come on Manuel let's go
while I would have enjoyed a nice comfy
hotel room this didn't even seem like a
forfeit for Joey all right so uh this is
our accommodation for tonight lost Cafe
I'm not content with spending what is it
like 5700 hours in a manga Cafe Joey's
now dragged me along and dragged me down
with him to spend the night in a manga
Cafe this is going to be like what day
four of staying in a manga Cafe on
camera
I must say uh it should be called the
lad Cafe because that's the lads are
coming in I'm parked oh God being a
little more enthusiastic I cannot let's
see what is let's go oh
oh oh this is how a winner should be
greeted with doors that open not sliding
ones that I have to open myself
[Applause]
I loved how much space I'm getting you
know is uh like I'm I'm a bit sad that
this is not ensuite you know like I like
I thought it was going to be we actually
kind of got a deal because at least this
one has a ceiling what do you mean a lot
of longer Cafe rooms don't have ceilings
and they just like oh Joey why didn't
you tell me we were living in luxury
Joey oh my God we get we get a ceiling
thank God I got a seat dude this is the
five star of manga cafes I'm telling you
we get our own [ __ ] room we get a
door not just like a flap
yeah that's pretty good not only are
like the individual beds not single beds
they're like kind of a twin ones are a
bit bigger than normal but like you
actually have room a desk as well a nice
desk you never get desks in Japanese
hotels it like just doesn't happen I
mean if you're American watching this
maybe this room is like not that big but
in Japan this is big not as big as you
yeah yeah we've got two screens right
here instead of one look at the TV here
I bet you Connor doesn't have two TVs in
the Sheridan a really big TV for a
Japanese Hotel look at those view oh
okay is it good not bad not bad yeah
there's not really a view I can see here
I don't know what con is doing right now
it's probably being smug as [ __ ]
laughing his ass off I can just imagine
his face I can just imagine his smug
face we all agreed that the top two
winners were going to get to stay in the
Sheraton and only the loser was going to
stay here in this manga Cafe but no Joey
had to drag me down with him but nice
that we have a bathroom right in the
room basically it's crazy it's like I
can brush my teeth while looking at the
staff's sleep
oh dude we can do our makeup here as
well yeah that's pretty poke actually
that's dude that's so good it sucks that
this is like the best lip part of the
entire building the orange juice apple
juice kind of gonna be so jealous we've
got a we've got an ice machine right
outside the room t as well dude [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] look at this vintage like
cigarette machine bro I might need one
tonight man I might need one tonight I'm
gonna start smoking tonight maybe
tonight is the right night to start
smoking how bad are you feeling that we
don't have mangas here though that does
kind of sound we don't have Manga Here
which is like the one bad thing oh dude
hentai here okay this has certainly got
a lot better yeah oh my God they got all
of bleach and all of Naruto I knew it
but hey I guess this is kind of weird
you can like see me foreign
but only very gently only your head is
the shower good oh I mean yeah it's it's
nice I'm pretty happy at least I can
finally get a good night's rest the last
two places were like super cramped so to
have like a room that is
cozy oh although I will say they try to
charge me 16 to use the pool what the
[ __ ] what'd you do Joe so I just bought
a shower coupon uh it's 300 Yen for a
shower and 200 yen to Red bath towel so
it's 500 yen for a shower how luxurious
we've got some food here very nice cup
Ramen I mean you've got to say it feels
Gonna Be A Winner I guess for now I'll
see you guys tomorrow I'm gonna rest out
and I'm sure the boys are too so I guess
we'll see you tomorrow in the car or we
start our journey to okayama so uh we'll
see you there bye guys well I've kind of
just been chilling here for a little bit
reading some manga and just you know
wallowing in my self-pity but uh you
know we've been up for so long and I've
been with like a bunch of animals and
stuff like that I kind of want to take a
shower so I'm gonna go do that dude I
must say out of all of the manga cafes
that I've stayed in the one reason why
this place is dope as [ __ ] this one's
got a [ __ ] sauna in it that's
actually kind of extra I guess without
further ado let's get naked well you can
play Grand Saga you can uh oh
what's this what's this
oh my God oh my God how many times do I
want to [ __ ] shower Jesus Christ is
this just gonna be the norm for me now
where there's scenes of me bathing in a
mama Cafe is that is that is that my
entire career now
[Music]
to be fair I am kind of enjoying this a
lot more thank God because uh I get to
watch you can't Suffer
Well if all else fails I can just catch
up to my anime I still can't believe
there's a goddamn sauna in a manga Cafe
this is great the Sheraton I'm sure
doesn't have a [ __ ] sauna suck a dick
Connor I know how much you like saunas I
don't even like saunas I'm literally
going in just despite Connor not to
mention I have it all to myself as well
because uh God was like no I'm not gonna
take a shower right now I'll I'll wait
till the morning you're probably trying
to read some goddamn manga in Japanese
aren't you
[Applause]
I can't read this
so I just finished having my shower it
was actually pretty good I mean the
sauna was a good uh stress reliever but
I saw on their website that there was an
interesting uh list entry of amenities
that they have and it just said that
they have rare amenities so I thought
huh never seen that before went to the
front desk and said may I peruse your
rare amenities
pulled this out
um I hope you know what this is I'm
going to take this home as a gift to
myself and go to bed
yes I'm not even going to pretend to
like try to fully utilize this place I'm
just tired now we've got so much more of
the road trip to go so yeah I'm going to
bed oh yes me
and just like that day three was upon us
[Music]
our boys are on the next leg of the trip
day four day is it day it's not day
three [ __ ] it feels like day seven
already yesterday felt like two days
what day is it I don't know like
sleeping in a manga Cafe I could have
slept for two hours I could have slept
for 25 I have no [ __ ] clue time
passes differently in the manga Cafe the
first word Joey said to me is he looks
at me in the eye goes what time is it I
gotta say boys it was luxury it was
amazing the best hotel eyes now it was
good it was uh I think for a five star I
thought I think they're a bit over
overreaching with that rating well I
mean either way I'll take a four star
over uh a manga Cafe I don't know man
did you have a sauna in your room okay I
had to pay 16 I'm never gonna forget
this fifteen dollars for just the pool
there wasn't even a sauna I feel really
well rested the breakfast was good the
only thing I want to say that sucked is
that at about 8 A.M the alarm radio
turned on and it started playing bomb
sirens and screams like
I'm like that's not a sound you want to
be hearing in Hiroshima by the way
yikes you know the room itself wasn't
too bad but then like as soon as I try
to get to sleep someone checked into the
door next to me I'm hearing this eye
like this squeak from I think it's a
headphone and then I heard
please no please and then gone turned on
the TV and went which one is
sync up we got to sing and then I didn't
sleep for another I think 20 minutes or
half an hour today we'd be driving to
okayama where we would be stopping off
at a rather unique place we are about
four minutes away from our destination
and finding out what we're going to be
doing for the day I have no clue it
literally looks like the middle of
nowhere I'm seeing a lot of home making
I saw a golf course are we playing golf
Joey there's no way the producers would
allow us to play golfer every day why
because that's fun Joey we're not here
to have fun Against All Odds though we
might have actually been given something
fun as somehow we had stumbled upon a
German theme park in Japan dude exactly
25 of my body is quaking right now is it
bad to think that I think this looks
like every like Town Square in every
jrpg this is just Final Fantasy this is
just a final fantasy this is like ryzer
we've just been informed by our
producers what we're going to be doing
today we are going to be making bread
our own brand I am so excited Mr all
bread tastes the same is gonna have his
first bread making I'm so excited to
taste this bread that's going to be the
best bread I've ever tasted have you
ever made bread before what do you think
what do you think I have let's go inside
let's go do it
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like the producers really knew
what they were who they were aiming this
towards so apparently we can uh make
whatever shape we want of the bread we
have our resident German staff here Manu
who's going to dictate who has the best
bread out of us three I can feel your
judging eyes Manny I can feel your
judging eyes God is here to atone his
sins well they all did the hard part for
us they like made the bread we're just
making the shape of the bread as the
only member of trash taste with actual
German ancestors the pressure was on I
like cute things and so I figured let's
go with something cute I'm gonna make
bread that's gonna make Manu go shiza oh
my God okay it's my logo with a bow tie
after channeling my European ancestors
and figuring out what I needed to do it
became clear that only one design would
do it for me my strategy was simple
among us all I'm saying is Beethoven
didn't need to hear to make great music
so do I need to taste to make great
bread
[Music]
the next challenge was upon us make
butter so JoJo found this is easy
[Music]
SMR you're making butter
just take a shot of the back and it just
like
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's so good what the [ __ ]
first edition who do you think is going
to have the best shape turned out mine's
got a lot of loose pots as much as yours
does so I'm a little worried yeah I'm a
little I'm a little worried it's gonna
be me of course I'm gonna be making the
best bread yeah because it took you
literally 20 seconds to make not all art
has to be complex sometimes Simplicity
is the key guys I bet you go to
Contemporary Arts museums on weekends
don't you no he does he does then it was
time to see the fruits of our labor
doesn't even look like it yes it does it
does yes no it doesn't no it doesn't
mine actually looks like Mike was out
all I'm saying is mine definitely looks
suss it does look sauce yeah it almost
looks like a manga's but if you got
bumped in there yeah dude you literally
have one shape to do you can do it but
this does look like Mike Wazowski he's
got his eyes no no this is what is that
that's his eye that looks like his anus
too no no no that looks that looks like
Microsoft I think it looks a lot better
now like it looks more Among Us than
before but I think like for Connor was
like because you have the details the
detail the detail yeah also Connor let
me stay in the nice hotel so I'm gonna
yeah
this is literally bribery caught on
camera how about we just agree that Joey
loses I think that's fair I think that's
fair all right I know I couldn't believe
you've done that to me I'm so sorry what
do you mean
what do you mean it should have won I
should have won no I'm sorry you're not
Joey lost that's the most important
thing but we get to make a tweet on
Joey's account and don't write something
that'll get me canceled well we had only
been scheduled for bread making we found
that the park was actually full of
activities to do and we might have let
out our inner child just a bit
[Applause]
[Applause]
that was so fun that was really fun well
the challenge wasn't as intense as
yesterday's but I still think we had a
great day today this was way more fun
than I thought it was going to be right
because we initially just came here for
bread making and then uh we found out
that there is a lot of things to do here
I wasn't necessarily German no but was
it fun absolutely did I nearly to kill
Joey in a car crash yes I did it was
nice just to have fun on a trash taste
special and not get pressured into
thinking I'm going to sleep in a shed
tonight or something like that right we
just had fun it was great we're gonna
head to our next destination which is
that's where we're going after the full
day of fun and activities we would be
staying the night in tottori where we
would be visiting one of the most unique
places in all of Japan the next morning
oh there's nothing else to do today
other than go to bed and then tomorrow
we'll be going uh doing the sand dunes
yeah we don't know what we're going to
be doing there but we'll see you there
bye
daughtery is home to the biggest sand
dunes in Japan and while we knew that
was on the itinerary nothing could
prepare us to find a site like this oh
what the [ __ ] that's so [ __ ] weird
where the [ __ ] are we this is Australia
yeah dude I I was about to say like
driving down here it looks and feels
like Australia what the [ __ ] that's so
weird looking like the change in
vegetation look at that I feel like I'm
gonna step on the stands and find a
snake or something the shore is so far
away so who's going to start singing the
Dune song
everybody
it would be a waste not to do anything
here but luckily our producers had
something planned for us you guys are
segwaying
who gets the best Segway because
apparently in this desert someone
thought it would be a great idea to
drive a Segway it's sand Segways I guess
sunsets where were they in Dune man they
could have easily outrun the sandwork if
they were just on a Segway you know all
right well I guess uh let's see who's
the best in Segway yeah
we'd all be riding Segways and honestly
we might have been enjoying them a bit
too much very easy that's pretty
intuitive you just lean where you want
to go what you say to me a little [ __ ]
let me get let me turn around there hold
on but hold on let me let me face you
real quick
what the [ __ ] you say to me what the
[ __ ] did you say [ __ ] did you say to my
cameraman remember the 360. oh my God oh
God oh [ __ ]
it's a long camera baby no kind of being
a monkey as usual all right let's do it
let's go let's go baby they see me
rolling
oh nice ass Joey nice ass show me those
buns oh god oh the double bun
yeah oh yeah baby that's what I'm
talking about this is so fun that's so
fun this is great holy [ __ ] kind of
feels like what I think skiing would be
like you know yeah on a flat surface
yeah
[Music]
I love this we should buy these
I should Traverse like this all the time
mailing can you invest in some Segways
please thank you may Lynn please please
we want some Segways
[Applause]
yo that's so cool come on
oh look at the view
holy hell dude we already like elevated
about like [ __ ] 20 centimeters but I
feel so powerful you know it's like the
modern day Austin that's probably one of
the coolest things I've done I thought
this sounds so lame segwaying on Sand
but no dude this is so fun
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let me see that dummy thick ass
my booty bouncing oh [ __ ] I nearly fell
I saw that the clap of your ass cheeks
is getting in the way Joey
oh you're approaching oh
I went
to said that is over this damn gone
you're gone how's that having a bit too
much fun there so one of us had to it's
okay guys I took the Elvis oh you got it
man
it's a dominance this uh dominance
well the guided tour was nice it
wouldn't be trash taste without a good
old-fashioned race a time trial baby
this time our producers have not taught
us what we're going to win but I'm
hoping it's going to be a Michelin star
meal or another five-star hotel
I need it it's gonna be worth the
struggle of putting my life on the line
yeah and speeding I've already fallen
off once I don't want to do it another
time that was like in the practice mode
to decide who goes first let's see
walking with scissors yeah
[Music]
wait how does this work well we do it
again
say sure good I can put [ __ ] ing such a
jury goes first
oh I got a second okay we're gonna be
doing a time trial over a course first
we would need to accelerate round the
corner and into the tricky bumpy segment
where God had a bit of a tumble earlier
turn around into the Gated path and
finally finishing things off perfectly
between the two trees through to the
Finish Line all while avoiding traffic
and potential kids in the way easy I was
the first up and I was certainly nervous
starting things off go
no you know that's not the acceleration
you want when you are doing a race
there's people oh God there's people it
seems to be going like max speed and I
think he just went the wrong way I went
the wrong way he's meant to go around
Joey oh is he must be disqualified
already right you might have did the
coursing correctly though and also you
missed one of the bumps yeah you missed
one of the bumps up there do you want to
do it again maybe yeah let me do it
again let me do it again three two
one go
and there he goes amazing posture off
the start there really good stuff you
like to see it okay so he's gone up now
he's doing it right this time it's good
to see you actually going the right way
oh it's so hard to accelerate [ __ ]
kind of keep up the speed though on the
bumps that's the real Time Saver all
right if you really want to go crazy
with it you can you can just full speed
it and there is kids running along his
path Bend at the knees baby Bend at the
knees
you got it all right here we go all
right pedestrian's in the way okay looks
like it's not going to be an issue he's
going for it though coming on the turn
this is the he's successfully avoided
the kids come on
accelerate
it's pretty scary to be fair you don't
want to hit the trees
oh okay and it's true he's just made it
and his final time yes
one minute 15 seconds dude it's so hard
to accelerate off that Hill not a bad
attempt Jay that's faster like I call
[ __ ] because you had a practice run
he basically had a practice run people
don't know that with my previous Victory
I felt a change in the air I could win
this the era of Choke dog VA is no more
good luck gamer oh he's really going for
that acceleration there oh no there's
somebody in my way no oh this guy's got
some trouble
that's good oh
[ __ ] my ass oh
yeah I'm good you're right you're right
oh that hurt my ass a lot I think it's
just his pride that's hurt I knew that
was gonna happen well then I I guess I
got us at least a solid second place so
you must say
all right let's finish this this is a
drinking special all over here
over again can't believe I choked
joke dog strikes again
well I don't think Connor won this one
and I guess it's on me now with Connor
out the running it was my time to shine
oh [ __ ] a bit of a slow start but so far
it's not the fastest start I think yours
are a little faster I think so he's
taking it quite precariously but he's
managed to get up there at a decent time
now he's okay
now he's going to be scared now he's
going to be scared
I'll be all right let's go take it slow
yeah and he's slowing down quite a lot
okay
can you get back up and save this though
he can save it he can save it he can
save it he's got it no it's not on it's
not on he's gonna turn it back on oh no
it's all going wrong for God oh my God
oh and he's driving like a pensioner now
he's going really slow and he's coming
this is a slow time so sad I'm so sad oh
he's taking it like a grandma now he's
slowly getting there the trees are
[ __ ] back a little bit is he gonna
hit the tree oh just misses it and he's
coming in and will he be able to beat
Joey's time in the time the time is one
minute 40 seconds which means your boy
gets the door too you think's going oh
[ __ ]
oh my God your boy had got the dub but
there was no time for rest as we were
straight off to our next destination so
we just finished coming out of totori
sand dunes legit so fun like it feels
weird leaving here at lunch time when it
looks like I just want to stay here all
day yeah right oh my God I could have
easily done that for like another couple
of hours at least of course it would not
be a trash taste special without a Sea
Dog VA choke
um I'm like but like I knew it was
coming like I knew Connor would choke so
I was like oh I won't leave my boy
hanging I'll I'll do it too I'll do it
too it's happened so many times people
are going to start thinking it's
scripted but it's not we swear it's not
scripted I guess no one could have
predicted the thing I'd break this time
with my ass
oh my ass hurts so much so like how bad
was the fall it really hurted actually
it's like a breather but also I was
worried that the guy would be like all
right no more no more Segways the
challenge is over if he saw that I was
in too much pain yeah so I was like [ __ ]
just get back up so go on here go and do
it so you got this job you got this I
was like the only thing that powered me
and kept me going was the chance that
God might also fall and [ __ ] up which he
did thank God it's not about how many
times you get down boys it's for how
many times you get back up and I got
back up oh you got back up oh he did get
back up all right I want to try sand
surfing paragliding there was a lot of
activities there that like you could
spend a day or two here and we had half
a day to ride some Segways which was
already fun as [ __ ] we've been told that
we're going to be finding out what Joey
won and where we're staying all at once
let me just say what you're going to win
is gonna absolutely change the game oh
well don't hype me up like that I'm like
sad now I'm sad that I didn't win oh my
god dude I'm excited I wonder is there
what's special about this place we're
going to Joe do you know anything about
it an inside sugar prefecture there is a
massive Lake it's the biggest Inland
Lake in Japan called biwako it's a lake
not a sea right when we get to it it
looks like an ocean because it covers I
think a third of the prefecture or
something like that it's huge as we got
closer it became clear where we would be
staying so it looks like we're just
about to arrive at our next place and we
are staring at an absolute Mega Chad of
a lake this is not a lake this is a
[ __ ] ocean this is so cool it's got
waves dude how is this a lake and the
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] Red Sea or like
the [ __ ] [ __ ] British people
British people be like [ __ ] you would
you [ __ ] Lakers you [ __ ] going up
so I'm seeing a sign there
that says b walked our campsite you know
what you know normally I would be
excited for camping but I just want a
good night's sleep so cold as well here
dude there was snow I didn't pack
anything wait how are we gonna count
we've got no equipment trash teeth try
not to die challenge give me capitalism
you know what give me civilization I I
love civilizations what was I expecting
this is a trash taste special we can't
have good things luckily though it
seemed like the producers for once had
poured through for us this place looks
pretty damn good this is this is the
premium Lodge as well we didn't just get
the regular ones we've got the premium
[ __ ] this is like the aesthetic Lodge
that you see in every movie like I'm
just happy that uh we don't need to
touch grass today right right we don't
need to touch it we are elevated above
the grass today so I need to sleep
inside so uh someone's looking twice
oh my
oh boy oh
sheesh so this is amazing oh my God this
is Vibes man don't we have a big fridge
here as well we got a big sink this is a
coal powered oven isn't it I don't know
I think this is actually I don't know
that clock is older than probably my
grandparents and then we got a fridge
it's it's nice to have it's nice to have
modern amenities you know I mean like uh
let's see where else we got big ass
fireplace over there as well oh every
room is an AC as well oh my God we won't
freeze today thank you cozy boys keeping
cozy this is too fancy for a cabin in
the woods this is like copper I love
this room this is my favorite room
welcome to
the room
Joey's like I need to find words there's
no specific room this is just space
right now but we have a nice little
balcony it looks like got a nice view of
the mega Chad right there as well I
would love to have something like this
like for myself just to like get Out and
Touch grass no no this you're getting
out but you don't need to touch grass
that's the beauty yeah you're raised
upon the grass but of course it was
never gonna be that simple but wait
there's more
of course there is I knew it
um actually only one person will be
staying here this is the one Joey's
getting isn't it maybe
well actually no [ __ ] no you'll be
getting something very special to help
him a large what can be more special
what could be very special about a large
oh oh you'll find out he like pulls out
the deed it's like the rights to the
launch congratulations on your win on
the Segway challenge Joey thank you this
is your prize
[Music]
not this price he already has a Tango he
doesn't need this yeah what is this a
jack off challenge wait Connor gets a
five-star hotel I get a [ __ ] box of
fat tissues Joey good to know that item
you just received will be helping you in
our next challenge is it a fap challenge
it is a fire making challenge u3 will be
making a fire what do we get for making
the fire you will be getting
a stay at this wonderful cabin outside
the woods so what you're saying is the
first person to make a fire gets to stay
in the log cabin and the two people who
don't start the fire stay in a tent yes
they will be staying in a wonderful tent
for one night well this sounds [ __ ] well
Joey's gonna win this well yeah that's
what I get for winning the Segway
challenge obviously I don't know Matt I
gotta redeem myself from the camping
trip that we took last time when I was
enabled to make a fire for 30 minutes so
this is my Redemption this man literally
had like store-bought Flint I was trying
for like two hours I couldn't start one
all right well uh it's uh getting really
close to sundown so we should probably
get started soon let's go make the fire
before we die the challenge was easy
make a fire with a flame that would last
at least 10 seconds we would be given 10
minutes to start off with and if none of
us were even close we would be given
flints to give us a little bit of a help
well time to successfully make a fire
how the [ __ ] I can't we have nothing how
are we supposed to do anything well I
mean I got the tissue this is true what
are you gonna lie to you guys ready to
go as ready as I'll ever be I guess my
knee also hurts and I gotta bend down
about oh here we go here we go
it's really oh we were off and it was
quite clear from the start that all of
us had absolutely no idea what we were
doing oh [ __ ] I don't know the [ __ ] I'm
doing what the f I'm gonna die in this
forest all right so my first okay you
gotta just get a bunch of uh I think
most of this Dead Leaves Dead Leaves
Dead Leaves Good Start uh maybe some
Twigs in there as well every single
Survival Game I know they make a little
fire pit it seems like the textbook
thing to do I don't know if it helps if
you can't make a fire but I'll figure
that part out okay now that I think
about it how the [ __ ] am I supposed to
use this Kleenex dude like I actually I
actually don't know
like is is are tissues not just like
cleaner Dead Leaves like how's this
going to help me oh [ __ ] dude I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
I just want to watch anime titties I
don't want to be here wait maybe I can
like Bank two rocks together will that
create a spark oh Jerry's using his
[ __ ] Kleenex
I'm just getting rocks in the kleenex
[ __ ]
I've got a yeah I actually need uh I
need trees let me try the Joey method
and just bang two rocks together don't
take my style dude I heard you Joey look
all I need to do is get a little bit of
this list dude this is not [ __ ]
working what am I doing
there's a lot of rock banging happening
around me oh my hands are just filthy
seven minutes left my hands are just
[ __ ] filthy this is this is useless
this is useless what am I gonna do think
think what the [ __ ] can I do I can't do
this I can't do this the right way
[Music]
everything before
me
ah okay I have an idea
I got a team this is how Tom Hanks did
it I made a poo stick
foreign
I mean I don't want to say but I got
some got some dry grass here I think
this is going to be better to use I
gotta believe Joey your tissues flying
away
no come back
no
why is it in fire
the only useful thing that this Kleenex
has done is made my hands clean that's
gross strategy it's uh
it's a secret technique that no weave
knows at all and that's why that's why
it's going to bring you to victory
what's Joey doing I'm banging two pieces
of metal together don't get in my way if
I just slam my [ __ ] on it with a light
on fire because that's probably more
likely than doing that
pretty soon we were begging for the
Flint but even then not all of us even
knew how to use them
how do you use this oh
when is POV come on come on when is POV
when is POV come on come on you got this
guy okay hold on hold on I can I can
read the instructions
you hit it Joey hit it
nothing's [ __ ] coming out are you
serious
oh oh
something's burning
no way
no
the t-shirts yes
feed it more tissues I guess the tissues
more tissues
[Music]
Kleenex came in clutch baby I finally
learned oh it's going out
a box of tissues that I had received had
clutched my win which was a relief after
seeing where the boys would be staying
tonight the [ __ ] is this
what is this I mean at least it's not on
the ground yeah you guys you guys get a
little uh wooden deck are you [ __ ]
shooting me I've slept in like a manga
Cafe and I like somehow we've downgraded
from that I'm just there's no problem I
can't even jack off here at least had
privacy in the market do you want the
kleenex this is not gonna be from my
dick it's gonna be for my tears that I
cry sleeping next to the car oh this is
the best feeling ever on a trash day
special dude this is the biggest dub
ever I've already cuddled Connor once
off camera why do I why do you why are
you guys making me doing on camera now
Joey was kind enough for us to uh stay
in his Abode while we eat before we go
to the camping sites unfortunately you
kind of can't drink right now I'm taking
pain meds for my knee which we looked at
the footage and uh yeah it turns out I
twisted it a lot yeah so we probably
gotta get Connor to our doctor tomorrow
but uh we'll figure that out played once
again played it play it one more time
Play One More Time
oh
ah the long day was finally over and it
was time for us to go to bed it's pretty
late
oh [ __ ] I can hardly see our way
this is [ __ ] found footage this is
the Blair way this is literally the Bel
Air Witch Project all right well at
least we've we've got mattresses wow oh
my God that's tiny that is not gonna fit
me that is it's honest they are freezing
hurry up dude why couldn't my
protagonist Powers kick in on this trip
where it actually matters like you've
lost everything I've lost everything
what happened in like the [ __ ]
drifting special oh you get dinner you
gotta pay for dinner no no now I get to
sleep on the in the [ __ ] streets
literally oh oh my God it's so hard oh
my God
man bruh oh it doesn't do anything oh
it's so thin
oh dude I thought I did my time when I
chose to be a monk like how am I still
sleeping on the floor it's good for your
back though right that's what they say
copium that's like pure topium hey the
last time we went camping and we didn't
film it was way worse than this yeah I
mean last time it was almost
life-threatening and this time it's just
really [ __ ] uncomfortable I really
really want to sleep on a bed I really
hope we don't have any more challenges
what are you using for a pillar just use
my coat we don't even have a pillow
fight we don't have a pillow right you
think they were going to give us a
pillow oh this is what else are we gonna
[ __ ] film I was just like wanking
each other I don't know like Joe JoJo
fans right well I guess this is us
[ __ ] signing off now [ __ ] you Joey
we'll update you tomorrow morning boys
see ya bye meanwhile I was enjoying my
win so much I just needed to remind the
boys one more time what time is 1209
right now the boys are asleep I'm gonna
go harass them
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and we have to leave we gotta make it to
the next trip but uh I gotta go wake up
we'll pick up the boys over there so
let's go uh give up a little drive-by
foreign
are you [ __ ] kidding me
come on let's go I don't want to go now
oh they're alive thank God
all right
was upon us and our plans had to be
slightly adjusted because
once again Connor had broken something
else on a trash taste special yeah so
the thing is uh we had some extra travel
plans for Tokyo today uh but
unfortunately on Brands Connor has
broken another thing on a trash tea
special his leg he's broken himself my
money is a bit [ __ ] which is not ideal
so we thought that we'd allow him to go
home and get checked off at the clinic
just to make sure everything's all right
and it will be a great time to take a
day off because I need a good night's
sleep as well I mean day of we're still
driving six hours to talk this is great
I'm doing nothing but driving you know
that's to me that's a day off you know
that's the day off
we'd lost a full day but thankfully
Conor hadn't completely messed up his
knee so on the dawn of day six he
prepared to drive up north it feels like
day 31 right now uh welcome to day six
sorry we didn't film a lot yesterday but
honestly there wasn't much to film
unless you wanted to see us be stuck in
traffic for about four hours that high
octane traffic cam today we are going to
be driving to where we drop a Duplo
again we're driving to Yamagata
Prefecture
Onsen which I've been to before it's a
pretty nice place I've skied there
before it's got one of like the most
acidic Onsen bats in Japan is that a
good thing or it like makes your skin
feel like super peeled that doesn't feel
like a good thing when you come out of
the bath if you try and like rub against
your skin your hand like won't move
because you just tore off like your
whole life again that doesn't sound like
a good thing you're making it sound like
a good it's a good thing I believe that
was a form of torture dude everyone
knows anything that is mildly
uncomfortable has to be good for you
the drive to Zao would be one of the
most scenic ones so far and that
includes the beautiful place where we
were staying tonight
this is the fanciest onset in this area
apparently and this already is way more
fancy than the previous ryokano oh is
that a private that's a private bath
over there check let's check that out in
the meantime God and I are gonna chill
out on these lovely couches while we
pervertedly stare at the bar this is
your like bathroom sink just for the
back and there's also a nice shower area
oh my God that's loud
foreign
why would you choose to go in this
bathtub when you have your own private
onset I mean sure it's better than the
uh old trash taste Studio oh we we just
remade the meme dude wait wait we could
fit two of us in there Joe come in here
all right well this is how JoJo fans
communicate
bye bye
bye our day was about to get even more
interesting though as a special guest
had just arrived but he needs like
another 20 minutes or something what
what he said he was at the car park
oh no he's right there
have no surprise guest everyone
it's Mr affable is it male to just get
40 more out of own hair I'm gonna be
only 40 I've stayed in here before oh
this one oh wait this exact room yeah
yeah how like is everyone going to sleep
we have two rooms
you can see you can see the little panic
in his eyes there for us
peasants yes of course Chris would join
us for this part of the journey and he
would start things off by giving us a
very affable challenge so we're in the
mountains of Yamagata and I have a
question for you three Do You Want to
Build a Snowman oh my God I want to see
who could build the snowman that is only
the best but the most like me in
appearance most like you are you sure
are you sure are you sure
I won the most drip-filled Slow Hands
ever committed to YouTube right you've
got 15 minutes to build the greatest
Snowman the world has ever seen that
looks as good as this that's it I've
also just found out that my shoes aren't
waterproof so
right these three they're just like like
[ __ ] Jesus on water going across the
ice did I come on and I'm going straight
[ __ ] through because I'm like 10
kilograms more than all three of them
combine but you've got 15 minutes and uh
that's it all right what's the loser oh
he's off he doesn't even started the
timer the Leisure has to take their
clothes off the top half anyway we don't
want to do that and roll around in the
snow for 30 seconds
we're not trying to get hypothermia here
20 seconds beat me halfway 15 15. 15
minutes to build the snowman 15 seconds
to roll in the snow here we go go
[ __ ] hell [ __ ] it up
I'm guessing it's quite painful we were
off and it looked like we all had our
own approach to making the perfect
snowman all right roll it roll it
rolling technique rolling technique
rolling technique
[ __ ] my [ __ ] Joey's doing a really
good job over there
and my hand hurts my hand oh my God
they're much bigger than mine already
[ __ ] it's not about size it's about
quality God the strongest of all
the biggest bull oh my God I heard so
much fantastic I mean Joey and God doing
great the other one no not so good all
right come on fly there the jacket is
off
oh my God is using Knowledge and Skills
he's using his coat
you know what my hands warm up this is
just a block of ice now getting a bit
warm in my ass cheeks God has built like
a [ __ ] monolith over there though I
gotta win this one I haven't won a
challenge yeah have you not don't be
giving your [ __ ] backstory
don't fix something that isn't broken as
they as they say so I stopped stock
strategy of making the classic snowman
ah Joe's made a little penguin look at
that
my hand is so purple That's not healthy
Chris that's you right that's you that's
that's your right shape right it looks
uh I'm not going to say anything till
later but we've got 10 minutes 40
seconds Joey's just Joey's just run off
he's gone he's disappeared here he comes
running across the ice like a rabid dog
you gotta make a face
[ __ ] okay that's not gonna work all
right [ __ ] the eyebrows that's his hair
let me clap that down
because I lost his head of hair right
there
[Music]
shape it out
this is this is good I would have liked
another layer of what of snow like a
snowman it's usually three layers isn't
it is it yeah in Animal Crossing it's
two layers we don't play by edible
Crossing rules oh it gave you a smile
too look how affable he looks I however
was sculpting a masterpiece Michelangelo
could only dream of doing all right now
to make it to shape this is a I've got
the basic shape down
and now I just got to shape it to
Chris's Immaculate form
what is that come on I'm going to shave
him that a lot just just you want for it
it's going to be a masterpiece the
craftsmanship The Carving it's gonna be
like the David Statue right this is
going to be like the second Renaissance
right here the second reincarnated in
the Snowman uh yeah I think the key word
here is optimism my fingers are
absolutely numb holy [ __ ] oh my God look
it's taking shape I've got he's got arms
now he's got arms hold on let me warm my
hands off and I'll finish this
masterpiece
I got a got a shape out Chris's drip
right here yeah yeah of course
look here I've given him a bow tie okay
I've given him a bow tie what can I say
I'm trying to give Chris the drip here
okay it looks like a map for Treasure
what is that it's gonna be Mike and
Angelo's statue right if Michelangelo
had no fingers Chris told us to make a
snowman that represents him so of course
I made the biggest snowman I could
meanwhile Connor just trying to make the
biggest snowman clearly [ __ ] my hands my
ass cheeks are the only thing that's
giving me some Grace here I got one more
pushing me the scene on Attack on Titan
where they're moving the [ __ ] balls
that have blocked the wall dude
oh
Connor's got the biggest the most
impressive like snowman Grant's got like
a he's crafting a masterpiece for the
ages and Joey's got some Twigs it's
impossible to say who who's in the lead
of this
but if it doesn't look like a snowman
like you can't win it needs to look like
a snowman it's gonna look like one it's
not like the most beautiful one I've
ever seen you better get rolling the top
one oh I'm knackers man I'm actually no
come on you can ride a horse you can
almost ride a Segway I can't feel my
fingers
[Music]
all right let's do this last one
[Music]
[ __ ] it's so cold six minutes Connor
you're gonna run so I know and there's
Connor's turn to just just disappear
he's going really far afield I don't I
don't think he's gonna get back in time
before the timer runs out I'm naked I'm
so tired is that Mr Penguin what is that
God and what is that that's just the
most generic snowman I've ever seen in
my life you'll see you'll all see
foreign
hairstyle looks like a [ __ ] palm tree
on the top what's going on here they
just snapped The Twig just snapped in
his hand
and with time up it was time for the
judges oh I start with Jerry let's hear
the concept for Joey's snowman first
this is uh that's a bit of a small small
snowman I like the little baby snowman
well the concept is if you actually look
in the shadows it says Mr raffle right
there uh Chris doesn't wear a shirt
that's affable though does he well I
mean it's a nice strip right also I was
the first one who gave him hair and then
Connor totally copied me so yeah but
it's not a competition for who's the
first one is it it's the best
what's that a hat looks like socks oh
well socks how big are your feet why do
I look so fat I look like a gimpy short
[ __ ] [ __ ] what is this well you
said to make you to look like slim and
tall and handsome and rugged what is
this [ __ ] come on man all right let's go
look at uh let's go look at Carl's one
what is that it looks like you've shut
up at the heart it looks like I've just
melted in an acid bath look at my face
okay I tried to do a little bit
something different with the face
because I saw those guys using Twigs on
whatever I'm like I can carve it like
marble out of marble but like I tried to
go for brought a different kind of body
type for everyone and everyone else you
see everyone went for a round shape this
is round you're having a laugh dude I
can clearly make a sphere I was like
Chris is Chris is built like a brick
[ __ ] house all right that's how that's
that's how that's how I see Chris all
right and [ __ ] of the week goes to
extra point to flattery Chris obviously
the drip King I gave him like a dinner
jacket with a bow tie as well well it
just looks like Penguin from Batman got
lost in a mountain
because his face so droopy where's my
smile like whiskers I was like I could
put him I couldn't give Chris a smile
but uh that would be out of character
how dare you it's interesting isn't it
all right let's go the statue of the
Statue of David's got nothing that's all
I'm saying closest to real height it's
nearly one to one that's just a boring
snowman
you've taken very artistic my arms are
right there my arms are right there dude
Chris has like child bearing hips like I
don't have like a breast here so you'll
notice right there's there's carvings on
the floor you might think there's
accident for me actually like shoving it
in that's actually the the you know when
you eat crisps you normally make a mess
so I kind of included that and it's like
right on his stomach yeah yeah it's just
someone's stomach you know they missed
some of the sides you know and it's just
big if you've gone for like the most
boring snowman of all time a child could
make that dude if he took off the drip
jacket it's just the snow not a smile
not a friend just a Snowman no it's not
take off the drip jacket it's a Snowman
I hate to say it this is actually quite
visually striking and good
more than I do but I have to give it to
him that's quite good it's tall it's
handsome it's it's visually striking
right I can't believe this all right
I've gone to my decision I think
right gone is without question the worst
the shittest unspeakably awful but it is
original yes yes you've done nothing
original it's just a bland vanilla shite
snowman take your top off roll around in
the snow you're the loser I am actually
about to unsubscribe oh my God it's done
it anyway
to time for my morning ball
three two one good good oh my God
[Music]
oh he's having a great time you you were
five seconds short but
we'll let it go oh after successfully
battling hypothermia it was finally time
to rest and prepare for tomorrow's
activities
today we thought it'd be a shame if we
didn't take advantage of the beautiful
snow around us so we went skiing
[Music]
get to join the big boys today so I feel
honored and humbled delighted excited
but also quite nervous we haven't warmed
up we haven't been down a nice easy
slope we're going right to the top I
came here a year ago and I actually fell
over and really hurt my legs so it was
very funny yeah Connor didn't really do
much to help the situation I did I I had
the bottom I was like
to do carry me there how can one man
carry such a colossal meme this is the
iciest
skiing through Connor's fridge what's he
talking about I haven't skied in about
10 years so it's going to be fine even a
good snowboarder
snowboarding
oh my God is this ice this was it the
start of the epic journey down the
mountain oh I haven't skied in so long
well for most of us at least
I'm going I'm going I'm going you are
watch me watch me go watching
foreign
[Music]
mountains very cold
oh God he fell
we fell
thankfully it looks like I wasn't the
only one having a hard time
this is going down on his ass
there's no greater feeling than tearing
it down a mountain especially when
you're with some good friends
foreign
's getting warmed up now let's go
yeah
with only three days of previous
snowboarding experience however the only
thing I was tearing was my ligaments
oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] thankfully the boys knew I
wasn't experienced and were kind enough
to wait
[Music]
look at Matthew flexing right in front
of me
[Music]
how did this happen
all of us got decapitated
this
who decapitated all of them what
let's go home I'm done I'm done
well I don't want to ski anymore now
let's ruined my day my baby's been
soiled [ __ ] steaks
we lost Chris you've just been skiing I
didn't die
what was on my mind is that I got like
two months before my wedding it'd be
funny if I sure got the cast wouldn't it
it's like a broken window
[Laughter]
skiing down the mountain was tons of fun
but unfortunately it came Time to Say
Goodbye to Mr Alpha boy it's been a
privilege to show you around the
alligator yeah yeah it was really good
you guys off to Hokkaido now of course
yeah yeah I guess yeah we'll see you
we'll see you around we'll see we'll see
you around it's a big car right yeah
bastard
[Music]
our next stop would be almori where we
would have to catch a nighttime ferry to
take us to Japan's final main island
Hokkaido now that we've managed to
successfully get rid of Chris uh thank
God onwards to Elmore yay yes the last
leg of the journey right last leg of uh
tohoku at least so we're on our way to
aomori which is the north most
prefecture in honcho so it's for apples
famous for apples I've never been to
Omari I've always wanted to go there
beautiful yeah I've heard it's really
really nice what makes our Morty apples
so famous why is it really good I think
it's the uh thank you for that Manu
really insightful piece of information I
think it's the weather is like perfectly
suited for apple orchards or something
like that I guess well the only thing we
have left to do now is to make it to the
end point let's go let's go
[Music]
foreign
we are just about to reach Narnia as you
can see uh we're about 20 minutes away
looks like I'm going through a wormhole
dude that's crazy it's like Star Wars
generally this this is like the hyper
speed scene in Star Wars right where
they go to Hyper Speed we were in a
desert like two days ago what is this
this is insane this this can't be safe
it's relatively it's not even that cold
either it's only one degree outside why
are the individual snowflakes so big
yeah right they're massive it almost
look like hail you know it only took
like I think like two like an hour to
cover the street yeah
anyway we're about uh 15 minutes and I
guess we'll see you guys when we get to
the restaurant if we survive through the
snow which looks like it's gonna kill
everything
foreign
[Music]
I've been on some pretty shitty ferries
before especially from like Island to
Island if we get our own private rooms
that's more than I expect
I guess we'll see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry what is this it's a double bed
hotel room what the [ __ ] yeah I mean
this is really nice I mean look at this
this is this crazy we've got a dining
table I love you
I mean I still got it's still got a
window see my God this is a million
times better than the young sugar one
not even close dude we got our own
private TV as well
to myself also a bathroom with a bath
which the Holy Ship is really rare oh my
God oh my God oh my God that's a big day
this is more spacious than most of the
rooms we've stayed in so far so the time
right now is uh 10 20 or so and we're
set to learn in chocolate around 2 A.M
so
at least two or three hours sleep
hopefully anyway I am going to take
advantage of this comfy bed and awesome
room see you tomorrow
we're going to go to our next hotel I'm
going to get as much sleep as possible
so I will see you all in a few hours
time to get some sleep last week all
right so I know you can't see anything
GoPro but the ship is vibrating so
[ __ ] loudly
I don't know if you can see this because
stabilization is on but it's vibrating
so loud and the tunnel just shut up
about for like 50 minutes it wouldn't
shut the [ __ ] up
but finally I hopefully I can get some
sleep even though everything's [ __ ]
shaking Jesus Christ this was it the
final day we would be covering all of
Hokkaido almost a third of our entire
route in one day and we had just one
goal finishing the trip
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
we were making some pretty good ground
then suddenly something very strange
caught our eyes where the [ __ ] are we
there's a lot of questions I have I have
some what look at the Easter eggs
what is this we just uh turned in
somewhere in Hokkaido and we've got a
bunch of Easter Islands brought Emoji
into a real thing what the [ __ ] bro bro
bro
what is this where have we come
where did we go
where have we come from cotton Asia so
it's a day in which is like a like a
cemetery spiritual ground what why do
they have Stonehenge there that just
makes me even more curious what the
[ __ ] hot in the middle of that bone I
was about to ask is that is that does
the real Stone Age have that makes it a
lot less impressive when you think about
someone just made this in an afternoon
with a big crate kind of loses all the
charm and the history
oh
yeah cricket
yeah exactly they just use this [ __ ]
thing to make this 20 minutes before we
got here my uncle Steve could make this
in an hour imagine if you got to the
Great Pyramids of Giza and then you just
see like a massive plane just like
lifting the blocks and you're like oh it
doesn't seem as impressive now yeah
probably that tall is it compared to
like the Burj Khalifa we figured out how
the Egyptians did it massive crying for
some reason in the middle of Hokkaido
there was a replica of Stonehenge the
Easter Island statues and the great
statue of Buddha oh it's 100 yen for an
inside stick oh sure let's do it I'm
guessing incense up yes
otherwise there'll be not much point of
you putting it on fire man just making
sure it'd be really awkward if I put it
in the modify
so then you're supposed to cleanse
yourself with the smoke it smells
amazing Thai building's a little
different from the Buddhism we find here
in Japan not too knowledgeable about it
I know that uh it's just a different
sect of Buddhism so let's have a look at
the Buddha statue we are cleansed and we
are ready to go see gone thank God I had
100 yen otherwise you wouldn't be
cleansed that is not that's so
incredibly cool
whoa that's so bizarre holy [ __ ] and
overreacting three two one
YouTube a thumbnail
oh
this is incredible this is awesome okay
won't kill you so by ringing this we
basically are communicating with Buddha
and like kind of giving him our blessing
or asking for his Blessing don't do it
do the honors Joey this is the biggest
[ __ ] camel kill you I've ever done
usually it's like this size or like a
little bit smaller
even that one's big so I just knock this
yeah sure all right let me let's let's
have the little little Golden Oak
oh my God that was loud oh this one's
gonna be a little bit louder wait this
is a Gong yep
don't knock it over
that's such a nice sound that's very
nice come on smack the gong Corner smack
the gun I know you want to so it's hit
on the top uh here on the side just like
look like tap yeah they've done like
foreign
constant ringing of the sound that just
doesn't fade it's just really calming I
think I've played too much album ring it
just feels like it's going to come out
and hit me
but this is where you pray and then you
activate the grace and it's like make me
feel things you know it's just like damn
okay I'm getting a little spiritual okay
again real spiritually
[ __ ] what an amazing piece how is this
in the middle of Hokkaido under what
purpose did they build a giant Buddha
statue right next to a replica of the
Stonehenge and the Easter Island statues
if it says very good luck go to the
Rotunda Cafe and store you get a free
party don't buy if you're not very lucky
you've got to spend your money in liquor
store it's like free latte what are you
doing doing a fortune oh you're doing
just a fortune yeah all three of us one
free drink wow you literally I was just
joking well well well boys I was
literally joking when he said free drink
the gods have shine down on me today
that's the best Fortune you're gonna get
like all year now I got I got 60 not so
good luck oh my God I got one free drink
at the cafe as well
I'm gonna go to the cafe and get my free
drink and pee well it says I'm gonna
come across some unexpected income so if
you want to go to patreon.com
we're in a place of God's gone not a
place of Shilling I can't believe this
man is Shilling in a sacred Place POV
you're a winner with drip this is genius
you know I I wasn't really into religion
until there was gambling involved and
then now I'm quite interested after our
spiritual awakening we had some bruh
moments waiting for us I just kind of
like don't know what to say when I look
at these Easter Islands it's like why
why is the first thing I say I know what
to say bro bro
so people used to start saying bruh
about three or four years ago online I
thought you're gonna say people started
saying bro about 300 years ago and it
was adopted by the internet so wait
there's there's stairs there which means
we could probably go up there we don't
have to stairs are for us yeah I mean
there's no sign anywhere that says don't
go up there bruh Joey is actually going
up there I'm clearly a child that I keep
thinking this is funny ah this is kind
of crazy that
these are here like when you just like
look behind me like this and I'm just
like hey guys so I'm here at the East
Islands today from this angle it doesn't
doesn't they kind of look like the Giga
chachin like that that one in the middle
especially
it's interesting I just want to know
like when they were placing the order to
like the Mason they were like so let me
get this straight you want you want like
30
giant stuff okay okay yeah we can do it
but like why why like okay okay fine
you're paying after that small detour we
had one job left getting to our
destination before Sundown so we could
get an epic shot of the sunset this is
like been like simultaneously the
fastest and the longest trip I've ever
taken it kind of feels like a month I
feel yeah it feels like a month but it's
only been eight days yeah I can't
believe like looking back how much I've
done in this past week I can't believe I
fixed my sleeping schedule I've been
working over like seven every day for
this road trip I'm waking up like a
normal human being for once this is what
it feels like to be 60. what it feels
like to be a functioning member of
society seasons have changed on this
trip yeah dude we've literally gone
through all four seasons and we've
covered I think what is it maybe 15
prefectures yeah almost 20 prefectures
yeah it's weird because you know how
like in a video game you get to travel
the entire open world in like one
sitting that's like we've just done that
in IRL you know we've seen every biome
there is to see in Japan why do you have
to call it a bio that's what it feels
like right we've gone from London South
we've gone to the desert we've gone to
the snowy mountains we've skied are you
are you secretly a Minecraft player yeah
I mean like I'm ready for this journey
to be over are you telling me that you
don't want to spend more time with me
guys I'm telling you that I've seen
enough of your face for a lifetime
listen gone is easily the messiest
person in this car and not only that he
never [ __ ] closes his door always
forget [ __ ] can never bring a mask so
it's like taking a toddler around with
you well just like I I don't know what
to say am I just like you don't know
what to say because it's all true God
it's all true and I'm sick and tired of
it maybe Conor just likes to complain
and follows something you know I do just
find something to complain every time
you know you're both a bunch of babies
sorry Mr I'm old enough for a driving
license oh I don't
know not really I think the final
challenge is to just try and make it to
wakano before the sun goes down
obviously we'll still be driving
responsibly though good luck to us but
we want to try and get a good shot of
the sunset if we can
we had failed but sunsets are overrated
anyway well guys I don't know if you can
see but the sun has set it's about to
get dark
that was just uh that was just Chewbacca
back there apparently
ready to head for the last the Final
Destination I'm ready I'm ready never
been more already well gentlemen we are
30 minutes away from the most northern
point of Japan
like
I threw up my eardrum why do you sound
like a locomotive trainer
trying to conjure up energy you know I'm
just like yeah let's Get Hype before
this final leg of the journey guys it's
nine in the morning right now uh our
original plan uh as you guys know was
trying to get there at Sunset yesterday
that uh turned out pretty horrible and I
need to know that we can we can cut that
we can cut that the important point is
we made it yeah we made it but uh yeah
how did you boys feel tired tired I also
just can't believe we actually did it it
feels like to me that I haven't had time
to really like reflect and soak in
everything that I've done and just
process everything because like I do
something and then by the time I get a
bit of rest I'm doing the next thing so
I'm probably gonna look back at this in
like a week or something and just like
[ __ ] fall on the floor because I
can't believe how much we've actually
done I'm gonna look back and be like I
should never tell Don what time to get
ready because he's never going to do it
on time gone get ready by 8 30. I'll go
in the shower at 8 30. what gone
operating on his own time zone I was
waiting for everyone else to take their
[ __ ] shower I'm sorry I didn't tell
you a shower did you take a shower this
morning Connor yes you did before 8 30.
all right boys when we're near the most
northern point oh my God
finally the goal is just there we are so
close let's see if the manga will be
gonna be like a small Spire with circle
around it I guess that's what I remember
from loving you know I really heard this
is not what it looks like just uh just a
laugh I hope it's just like a [ __ ]
sign that says like you're here well
there's just nothing there's just
nothing there it's like believe us
you're here needless to say I think the
southernmost point was a bit more Scenic
I gotta say this this is has been a
depressing looking Coastline most of the
way here our boys all right we are 500
meters away and I don't see anything oh
yeah no yeah there it is oh wait no I
have seen that before love heena didn't
lie to me thank you aquabops Ken this is
it this is the most northern point in
Japan I'm going to take a [ __ ] in the
most northern toilet in Japan oh yeah I
was looking on Google Maps Apparently
that is the north most public toilet
dude [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the Spy I want to go
to the north most public toil in Japan
all right boys
it's the most northern point
oh my God we're here we're about to hit
it guys and I love how they made it so
obvious that we're here this one was
actually way more obvious than the
southern Point like this one has a
dedicated Monument I'm glad this
Monument exists because now we can't
[ __ ] it even says the most northern
it says in English so we can't [ __ ]
our audience we're actually here they
literally we've actually made it they
literally subbed it just for us
the north most point in Japan we did it
like Thanos with The Infinity Gauntlet
ready all right ready three two one
let's [ __ ] go let's go oh my God
[ __ ] hell it's so [ __ ] cold well
there isn't much to do here I can't take
a dump in the most northern toilet and
also visit the most northern restaurant
and the most northern uh public brothel
or something I don't know one of the
most northern soap land but I guess
we're done with this road trip we did it
that's it well I hope you guys enjoyed
the journeys after that we just went on
yeah thank you for watching the trash
taste road trip we'll see you guys in
the studio bye
I need to take a [ __ ] as well actually
we had done it 3 000 kilometers spanning
all of Japan getting to experience some
of the most amazing things this country
had to offer after all that there was
just one thing left to do
and there you have it guys that was the
trash taste road trip special
to the boys we did it we did it yeah as
we mentioned before that was a cut
version because we had to cut so much
banter in the car so if you want to see
an extended director's cut let's call it
a director's character yeah then just go
over to a patreon at patreon.com
trashtaste we really hope you enjoyed
this trash day special it took a ton of
work and New Legends over at the patreon
helped make this happen so give it a
consideration well thank you so much for
watching this trash day special we'll
see you next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
don't like change but I'm not afraid I
can't keep it together
thank you
[Music]
foreign
entire [ __ ] cow that Stoney come to
me help me
help
holy [ __ ]
I'm a little worried I'm a little scared
as to how fast this thing's gonna go
especially because again I've driven
manual once in my life let's go for
America baby
[Applause]
clutch in